ladies and gentlemen chloe feinman
[Applause]
[Applause]
holy
i'm really nervous to meet you i'm so
excited i'm such a fan
i'm your biggest fan you're gonna make
me cry i i'm gonna cry
i just i've always first of all comedy
to me
is i think more than medicine it's what
saves us in the world yes it's like the
most attractive quality in any partner
it's the thing you want with your
friends it's what you look to
entertainment for
laughing is the most important thing in
the world but your
talent your range the way you play all
the characters
if it's okay we're gonna cut to
commercial break and then i would just
love to
display your work and ask you your
process because i am just
in awe of you i know by the way
me that you are i am in awe too of you
um welcome back okay you just saw our
guest
chloe feynman the phenomenal chloe
feynman and we're both
a little shaky because we're so excited
to meet each other and this is the first
time
we've been face to face truly um i
the one thing that i think makes so much
sense also for like a show like this for
you to do is it's
i just thought what a perfect platform
for you to put yourself as all the
guests
and it was like a great sort of
plug-and-play you're nicole kidman
i mean if you close that's nicole kidman
it was nicole the reese
i love when you do timothy chalamet oh
thank you
oh i thank you what's not to love about
your process i know that you're whenever
i
would start a character for a film i
started hair first
ooh and that was just my way into the
person like
hair is a big thing with me and i know
that you have like a good
wig collection yes we do like there are
little hairs everywhere from constant
trimming
yes yes from timothy chalamet i do start
wig first
now that i think about it um he was i i
went on amazon and got like a
gaston like beauty and the beast wig
and then i covered it in coconut oil to
give it like a rocker
sexy vibe and then trim trim trim and
then yeah because it really turns
hair is everything hair is there's
something about it and i love because i
remember when i watched the very first
snl back that was really raw you were
the only one rocking like
accoutrements and then i think there
should be like a peabody or a
pulitzer for what snl did from one week
to the next i think it showed everybody
what was possible in 2020 it was like
a level of innovation i just it blew my
doors off
and um but i love that you always
commit because i think that sometimes
especially when it's like impressions
you just want to fall into it
so the way that you design everything
really
i think helps that delicious spoon feed
you don't have to over concentrate
you get right in and you start enjoying
at like word go
do you realize that that's what you do
for people i
don't but that's such a nice thing for
you to say i mean doing you was so
exciting because you
were on the cover of in style and it's
the impression that i did this summer
started because i really wanted that
shirt
it was so cute which got sold and raised
like ninety thousand
dollars i know the park scholarship
foundation totally so i was like
swipe order and then it came in and then
i luckily in la
had a large uh wig collection in my
boyfriend's
shed and i heard some of the clothes you
wear are his
if you need a male yeah yeah thing
you go to go to hit yeah so it was lucky
to have like all these
things when you know the world was a
little shut down
i you brought so much joy i immediately
reposted that and then i was afraid i
was gonna drive you away
no i'm not kidding i was like oh now she
knows i'm on to her she's
gonna she's gonna move on and i'm she's
gonna lose interest
another man in your life that's very
important to you
is your dad okay so you guys do
improv together we do still to this day
um when my mom was pregnant with my
younger sister
he would take me to improv in san
francisco at the fort mason center and
it's an every saturday drop-in class
that has been going on for not to reveal
my age
but over 30 years and uh we still go
i you know i heard a rumor that barbara
walters said if you like
want to make someone cry ask them about
their dad and i feel like that's
especially true
for us girls you know i have
like when i talk about my father i
always get like misty-eyed um
and he wasn't like we didn't he wasn't
really around but he was just a really
magnanimous like interesting soul and
there's something so
you know emotional and beautiful about a
father-daughter relationship
and they're all impactful mother
daughter father-son mother-son oh my god
the mother-son one whoa
yeah um but i love that you guys do that
and jason sedakis another snl
alum said that he and his wife take
their kids to improv class
really and do you think that i should
take my kids
absolutely you should you absolutely
should we because of the pandemic
started doing it on
zoom uh through the groundlings i'm
close with my teacher annie and she let
my dad
be like the creepy old guy in the improv
class
was there an aha moment for you like
when you were younger was there a moment
at life was it collective
where did you say i know how to do this
and i want to do this and i'm going to
find my way step by step to becoming
like literally where you are
at this moment gosh i mean i think
growing up
i was lucky to have really funny i'm
from cal berkeley california
and so yeah yeah yeah yeah
you're not you don't seem to have that
horrible accent that i've stuck with for
the rest of my life
it's there it comes out uh but my like
these
wacky hippie doodle you know
free-spirited girlfriends growing up and
so we were like really encouraged to
just be funny and loud
and that was a way to you know feel cool
it wasn't about like
dressing and the little dresses and you
know
we were just wild playful do you have
any
suggestions for anyone who wants to
try comedy uh do improv
do an amazing reenactments of people i
mean you
you just have that gift and it's so
about
the voice too like do you have one
tip if someone's watching and just wants
to start playing in their closet today
yes uh yeah oh god one tip would be
it's dress up i would get in the costume
and kind of it's a dance like no one's
watching
you know just i think if you're like i'm
gonna just be somebody else right now
and
get lost in that that's that's usually
like the
the first secret it's just like lose
yourself okay last question do you talk
to yourself in the mirror
yeah of course oh my god me too okay
good
i'm so relieved yeah it was always a way
for me to just
live out fantasy totally totally and i
think i mean i have a
memory of like starting to do you
miss drew i was in brooklyn um staying
with my friends and i saw some video and
you
i don't know i was just fascinated and i
was in the mirror being like
hello i'll be in a mirror a pair
a duo with you anytime
um i hope you'll keep doing this on the
show i'm like always afraid i'm like
that's
it that's an alien conference never
doing it again no you never i hope so
i just you're my holy moly only for life
and i'm so thrilled you're here
thank you i am shaking with excitement
thank you chloe
thank you for honoring us with your
presence here
and um snl airs on saturdays obviously
at 11 30 on nbc and this week they've
got issa ray and justin bieber
okay chloe do you want to toss us to
break yes
yes here we go we're
in the pretty little middle of our show
and
sunny side up is the sweet and stylish
and
oh so successful jessica alba
[Music]
you